fallout fans on xbox one have something
new to look forward to the free-to-play
mobile spin-off fallout shelter is
headed to Microsoft's console in
addition to Windows 10 I'm Matt and this
is your micro transaction free gamespot
news update Bethesda has announced that
the xbox one and Windows 10 versions of
fallout shelter support Xbox play
anywhere allowing you to carry your
progress and achievements back and forth
between the two platforms an xbox wire
post says that the game has been adapted
for xbox one controllers but no
specifics were mentioned fallout shelter
hits xbox one and Windows 10 on februari
7 but if you're on PC and don't want to
wait you can play it through Bethesda's
app right now the game revolves around
you designing and managing involved in
the followed world and since launch its
expanded its feature set and roster of
characters adding some of the more
memorable ones from fallout 4 we'll keep
you updated a fallout shelter comes to
other platforms so for that and more
from the world of video games stay tuned
to gamespot
[Music]
you